first cade cunningham the number one
overall pick
keeps a streak intact it is now 12
straight years that a one and done
player
goes first in the draft of course first
with the interview
is our very own taylor brooks who caught
up with kate cunningham
kate cunningham the number one overall
pick in the 2021 nba draft
headed to the pistons what emotions come
with just hearing those words out loud
a bunch of emotions um but you know
more than anything it's just happiness
um excitement
and you know i'm just glad i got to
spend this moment with my family you
know have them in here with me
to you know experience this this is a
big moment we've all been waiting on
this
and they you know my support system is
what helped me get to this point so
it's a bunch of emotions but i'm just
happy to be here for real absolutely and
you know you always said you're going to
be the number one pick
so much so that you only met with
detroit in that meeting what did you
learn about the role the pistons see for
your future
you know more than anything they they
look like they wanted to push me to be
the best that i could i could be
um i really believed that whenever i was
talking to them
and you know that's that's what was most
important to me is that they weren't
gonna take it easy on me as a number one
pick
and that they were gonna push me to be
great so um you know i left feeling
great i left feeling like you know i was
stepping into a great situation
and now i'm excited to be able to go
deliver for him yeah
so many expectations come with being the
first overall pick
tell me about the expectations you think
other people have for you and the
expectations that you have
for yourself yeah i mean like you said
number one pick you know
you want to come in and really elevate
the organization
and so you know that's the expectations
that i've had on myself for any team
that i played on
um and you know i want to i want to look
back on my career
and be proud of the things that i've
done so you know i'm going to take pride
and make a city i can deliver for
detroit for the city of detroit um and
be that guy that they're looking for
i know lastly i see your adorable
daughter over there
yes she's so cute and one of the great
things about kids is they just go with
the flow they never know what's going on
how are you explaining to her what's
going on tonight with her dad
i mean she knows everybody's cheering
for me oh
yeah she kind of just gets the gist of
it but you know i think
down the road we got plenty of video and
stuff around right now so
down the road she'll definitely get it i
think she'll be happy to to
see all those videos and relive that
moment well dad is officially
an nba player yes welcome
congratulations kate we look forward to
watching
a long career for you in the league
a 6'8 shooter reminds me of another guy
on this set so smitty let's start with
you on gabe cunningham
uh what does he bring to the table as
the number one overall pick going to the
piston i think first of all i'm sitting
next to brian shaw who played that
position we both
handled the basketball so i'm biased
from guys that are 6'8
that can handle the basketball and then
you go into a city that understands and
knows basketball
what i think about kate cunningham is
you can't speed him up and i'm not
talking about on the floor just in that
interview
you can't speed him up even off the
court he's ready for this moment his
support system
they have obviously been fantastic you
can just tell them
everything he gets it right and what i
love about him everybody talked about
he's not that athletic
well the guy named the jokic from denver
i don't think he's jumping over this
piece of paper anyone mvp when you have
a high basketball iq
and you understand the basketball game
you're going to figure it out and the
reason why i love him is watching him
play in college he was the first
he was the second and the third option
and he wasn't selfish but he could still
get his points
and make other others better he's ready
for this moment he's built for this
moment
at 6 8 whether he becomes a point guard
throughout his old career
he'll have a defined position in his
league because he has a high basketball
cue
as a basketball player we don't have a
lot of basketball players
and he's one of them you know that's a
good point so brian what position
does he play in the league he's just you
know it's a position this
positionless league uh you know as we
see it right now so
um he'll be whatever position they need
him to play
he'll do whatever they need him to do on
the court one two three
um you know he brings a lot of savvy he
brings poise
uh patience obviously he has the size
the the basketball iq to smitty's point
and when you saw that interview um you
know detroit and their fans
can't help but be happy um with what
he's going to bring
you know it's this moment is not too big
for him
um the maturity level that that
you see that he exudes when he speaks um
he's going to be a great leader for that
team and i think that he's going to come
in and do a tremendous job
they could have messed this up they did
not sometimes when you have the number
one pick
um in certain drafts you can take a
swing
and miss detroit did not hear to your
point
obviously it's about wins and losses we
know that and troy
weaver leading this group in the
management team in detroit
knows it as well but they are getting as
you said a complete person
someone who's ready for and will embrace
all the responsibility that comes with
being the number one pick
on a franchise that is desperate
to have a face forward player
uh someone who can they can put out in
the community we know how prideful
people in detroit are
yes indeed got one on this set okay and
we know
they are a championship city they have
been
champions before this franchise has a
great history
and so it needed someone like this they
were very lucky to get the number one
pick
in a year when you can get someone like
kade cunningham